I broke this course into four
stages that built on one another.
You'll start in the wrapping stage
where you'll be learning the syntax
of constructing promises.
A promise constructor in and
of itself isn't super useful.
So from there, you'll be learning how
to react the resolution of the promise.
If all goes well, you'll want to then
off the promise, or if something breaks,
you'll want to catch the error, these
are the thening and the catching stages.
You'll spend the whole second
lesson in the chaining stage
where you'll learn how to create
long sequences of asynchronous work.
It's also worth going over
some promise vocabulary.
I'm stealing these definitions from Jake
Archibald who wrote a fantastic guide on
promises that you can find
in the instructor notes.
There are four states
a promise can have.
You'll pick up these terms pretty
quickly, but I recommend jotting them
down on a piece of paper to help out
as you're going through the course.
Here they are.
The first one is fulfilled, and
that means that the action related to
the promise succeeded,
this state is also known as resolved.
Then there is rejected,
this means that the action
related to the promise failed.
The next one is pending,
which means that the promise has not yet
fulfilled or rejected.
And then finally, there's settled,
which means that the promise has
either fulfilled or rejected.
Okay, now that you've got
the terms behind promises and
you know where we're going in
the course, it's time to examine how and
when promises are executed.